a different perspective can make a hell
of a difference blood-borne in top down
mode plays pretty good it might remind
you of some of the first GTA games or
Diablo and as soon as I saw this glitch
I was like yeah I'm gonna record my
entire video in this perspective this is
awesome
but no turns out that's not really
possible the camera is stuck at this
height and a lot of old yharnam is
underground so you won't have much luck
getting anywhere
I spent roughly three years trying to
get to the blood starved beast like this
and eventually I did make it to her boss
room she wasn't in it and neither was I
apparently both bosses and their doors
had ceased to exist because you can walk
through the dark beast piles boss room
which shouldn't be possible at this
point in the game after you've
encountered dark beast pile you can
actually talk to Jura the hunter atop
the tower to do this we have to approach
juror from behind which means that you
have to kill the dark beast and take the
door behind him into old yharnam or you
can also simply encounter the dark beast
and then warp to the church of the good
chalice which is where you fought the
blood starved beast and you can walk
back from there well well how did you
get in here
it's no matter beasts do not venture
above and mean no harm to anyone if you
still insist on hunting them then I will
hunt you first you understand me
agreeing to spare the beasts gives you
the brush-off dusty mode as well as the
powder kick badge you can get the badge
easily by killing him as well which also
unlocks his set for purchase in the
dream the easiest way to kill Jura is to
shoot him four times with a pistol as
soon as you get to the top of the ladder
or you can poke him with an extended axe
just make sure you reload your game and
the badge will be at the top of the
tower with you if you go down one ladder
from Durer and you walk straight you'll
land on another platform that brings you
into the rafters of the adjoining
building and up here there are two
things that are important the first
thing which is really easy to miss is
the fact that there's actually oil urns
hanging from a rope here if you cut the
rope the oil will fall down and the
beasts below will either be set ablaze
or be really scared of the flame which
makes the room below a cakewalk sorry
and there's more up here walk across the
rafters carefully and off to the right
you'll see a platform with an item on it
there's a jump to be made here though
falling from this height is pretty easy
and pretty risky you do it like so and
you'll pick up the bloody messenger head
bandage an accessory adored by the naive
messengers who don't know what these are
why not let them be happy and revel as
babes there are such little cuties back
in all the annum I'll show you an easy
way to kill the source bear hunter I
learnt this from the guys who did the
hunter of hunters challenge which was
this really awesome challenge that we
did a couple of days ago you should
check that out if you're looking for
something to watch after this one
anyway if you trap an NPC outside of
their aggro range they'll attempt to run
back into it and won't be able to attack
so if you dodge through an attack you'll
end up on the other side and you can
trap the sauce bear hunter on the stairs
for an easy win alternatively you can
open this shortcut aggro the sauce bear
hunter and then sit on the ladder and
wait which is pretty risk-free the last
few things are to do with the blood
starved beast number one as her name
implies she's highly susceptible to
pungent blood cocktails so lob one if
you need to munch on some antidote or
want an easy shot at her second she's
incredibly weak to fire and thirdly did
you know that you can summon Alfred for
this fight right next to the stairs is
his summon sign and you can just ring
his Bell if you need assistance and I
have a challenge for you guys to finish
us off it's something that I couldn't
figure out no matter what I tested so
when you die to juror he says I should
think you still have but according to
the wiki and a lot of forums that I've
read apparently he says the next time
you dream give some thought to the hunt
and its purpose for some reason his
dialogue is cutting off early as of the
most recent patch and now I assume what
happens is we die before his dialog
completes and I've tried dying in slower
ways to get all the dialogue
I've tried mashing X as soon as it
starts I've tried setting myself on fire
so it takes longer to die but nothing
works and I'm really confused why that
other piece of dialogue seems to exist
online so if you guys have any ideas or
you know why this is or if you've ever
heard his full dialogue
- no in the comments below I'll be
reading them as usual and I really need
to get access to that dialogue if I want
to do a low video on Jura I think but
anyway thanks for watching guys I know
it was a short one but we have another
one coming soon and then we got some low
videos really excited I'll see you guys
next time